happy are you at all concerned that you  you do such fabulous work on broad city  are you at all concerned that's a show  that's a show that can get quite edgy  quite adult are you ever worried that  the children will say you know I've okay  I've seen it I've heard her I loved  during the Ninjago lego movie I've got  to go check out this broad city all the  kids are talking about interesting  enough there's a lot of common themes  this season season 4 comes on September  2 and if there's a lot of father-son  stuff going on right a lot of ninja [ __ ]  on this show if they're like is this  actually a lot of parallels ok so I  think it does crossover so a child at  loves lego ninjago movies should go and  watch all the broad city alright let's  move on  you